[Music]
we know in this movie it was such a
departure from the role that you play on
Riverdale in a sense like you're kind of
this like mean girl in this movie so
what it was like to kind of shift and do
the different roles I shot this actually
way before I even booked Riverdale so I
started with this and then went back
this is actually like the first really
like mean role I've ever played Thorin
Patrick Norton a let's talk about
Riverdale a little bit we saw the return
of your character this week and we saw
the twins and then we saw chicks
creepiness get even creepier what is
that about what can you tell me about
that family dynamics because we learned
that he's not who he says is well I
think the family dynamic with the
Cooper's you never know what you're
gonna get and you're like one second
you're like oh they finally gotta figure
it out open everybody like everything's
going crazy a guy they're like
everybody's changing and you're like
what is happening what so many secrets
everybody has so many secrets and it
doesn't stop why does she keep lead and
then coming back she doesn't want to
leave her family she really wants to
give her family a chance and but
ultimately it ends up being what she
decides to say that's for her and her
babies mostly her babies so I think
that's why she comes back in some chance
and then like this time she comes back
and she's like okay well mom and sister
are good but now there's this creepy
brother will we see her again before
season's end I think so I think you will
yeah probably doesn't go away she's down
I think she knows that like home is
where she's supposed to be and where she
wants to be I feel like we're gearing up
for some sort of war and Riverdale did
always feel like that though because I
think definitely you know is towards the
end of the season goes some things get
uncovered some things get solved some
things don't you know it's it's always
riddles ever-changing and I think that's
not gonna change by the end of this
this season so you're gonna teething
things I can't give it away but like I
want to like him yeah
[Music]
[Applause]